I'm Ryan labove I currently work for
envoy where we challenge the status quo
of workplace technology it's a Bay Area
company super fun most of the time I'm
doing ember and node stuff but since
it's a startup I do a little bit of
everything so kind of like revisiting
the goals for today given this map we
have with the big X I want to help you
see like where you are in like help
debunk some of the myths of the journey
to help you get the job and this is all
leading up to the fearless interview
some anti goals I'm not going to teach
you computer science in 30 minutes it's
not possible and I'm also not going to
help you fake your way into a job so
anyways let's get started the quest map
I kind of broke it down into six six
parts one is learning how to code two is
getting your first tech job three is
preparing to look for a new job
four is the job hunt five what we're
leading up to is the fearless interview
and six is kind of a postscript of being
at the X and throughout this talk I've
talked with literally all of my friends
who code and had them just give advice
that they found helpful along the way so
it's a you'll see quotes from a lot of
lot of randos that I really respect so
learning how to code this is your magic
weapons that you find and it's
interesting I was talking with John
Moses of one of my friends and he's
actually giving a talk about this in a
few weeks so I'm not gonna like try to
go over at all he's got a great series
on it he's going to speak more about it
in about a week here two or three I
don't know but my TL DR is like learn a
language build internet things meet
developers share what you build I
personally learned how to to code on
this this book called the Ruby on Rails
tutorial where we built Twitter from
scratch free code camp is great there's
another one by Colt steel I highly
recommend you build Yelp from scratch
that's not the point though it's just
like it's a lot less important where you
start as long as you pick something and
finish it that's kind of my point for
learning how to code
after your bootcamp experience this is
where the real work begins you need to
build something on your own if you don't
know what to build I recommend starting
with a blog because it's like really
easy to like you know what a blog is and
you can build a very small or a very
complex one you can ship it people can
read it you have users you have
something to talk about like my friend
Jordan Smith says be honest keep
learning and talk about what you learned
so after you build something cool this
is where you start signing up for
lightning talks free code camp okay CJ
is the Ruby group wherever you can talk
you need to share with share what you
learned just keep building things get as
far as you can on projects make them
dumb make them fun make them something
you use there's this guy Ira Glass he
has this little short story called the
gap and it's about creatives about how
like when you start in a new field you
like you like I want to be a painter
it's like I see these amazing paintings
and then you paint this just like
terrible thing it's like how do I get
from here to here and everybody goes
through this it's exactly the same with
programming and his answer is do a lot
of work a huge volume of work and that
volume of work is what helps you close
the gap and eventually the quality of
your work will catch your ambitions so
if you're still stuck on this West boss
has this thing called JavaScript 30 you
build 30 s from all things in JavaScript
over 30 days you'll probably make it to
day 13 and be building something really
interesting that you like and like
you'll just go off on this tangent
that's what you want that's great that's
like a sign that you're doing the right
thing so the boss battle for learning
how to code can you use get and github
do you have like a side project that you
can point to that's like I built this
thing and it's on the internet now I can
prototype stuff in HTML and CSS I can
solve basic coding challenges with
JavaScript and also I understand the
basic workings of an API this is like a
pretty good start which segues into
getting your first tech job so
especially if you go through free code
camp you've built some stuff on your own
you want to get paid like you want to
start working in tech and so
before your first step Tech job I
personally felt like everything I did
was just a string of terrible failures
with programming and then somehow like
as soon as you learn your first Tech job
this is where you feel like you're on
the fleet of NAR whales cruising through
the lava sea it's just like I don't know
that's really big and it feels a lot
like getting your big break but a
question I get a lot is how do I know
I'm ready for my first job in the
industry so this is where I have to
remind you everybody started somewhere
everybody was a junior nobody came out
just programming so my rule of thumb is
if you can build something useful
you're probably horrible to somebody you
don't have to know everything you just
have to be able to add value to the team
that you're joining that's like a really
important thing be very open about your
current skill level you don't have to
hire lied about anything but also don't
undersell yourself like especially if
you come from a job that has like a
customer service background a lot of
programmers after 10 years turn into
like sea creatures and though I can't
talk to people so like you bring very
valuable skills to table just by being
able to engage with the customers it's
like these are very valuable things that
you bring to the team so I really like
Queen Carmen says it's okay to say you
don't know something much better than
making something up specific warnings
for your first job in tech you want to
make sure the team you're joining is
ready to bring on juniors some questions
I suggest asking one do you have other
juniors on your team - are there people
on staff who were a junior but now we're
no longer juniors that are still with
you three how did what kind of
mentorship do you have for juniors how
do you make sure that they continue to
progress and four are there clear job
bans
how and how often would we reevaluate
whether I'm still a junior and I'll say
personally envoy this is something we
always come back to you and it's like I
think it's hard for companies to get
this right and so it's like don't feel
bad if you're at a company it's like
we're trying to do the mentorship
program the important part is just to
keep asking yourself these questions and
trying to make sure that answer
continues to improve John Moses Minh
says get a friend that can get you a job
honestly this is probably the hardest
step in the whole process so harder than
like getting building that compiler or
doing weird video game stuff is getting
your first job that's like pretty deep
for somebody who's been in the industry
probably at least 10 years so boss
battle first tech job from this job
you're gonna want things on your resume
you're gonna want to launch something
monitor actual software maintain it deal
with customers these are all skills that
you won't get from anywhere else
specifically you want to make sure
you're continuing to gain more
experience collaborating with other
programmers this is something that's
very unique to actually having a
programming job and at the end of this
you really want to make sure that you no
longer consider yourself a junior so
that willing leads me to my next point
it's preparing to look for a new job
this there's a lot of overlap between
the first job but this is where I find
is actually my personal journey was like
the hardest point because I worked for a
company for maybe six years and like it
at some point I felt really stuck and it
took me a long time to figure out how to
continue to ramp up my skills to get
ready for the next stage in my career
and again going back to our metaphor
like this is where you're kind of like
I'm kind of a grizzled veteran already I
probably don't see this if you've been
working in a job for one to two years
you've changed your shipping software
whereas before you or not this is this
is like massive changes in you so I
break this down into three parts and
I'll go over them one is to prove your T
which we'll talk about because that
sounds really weird slash are slash into
context
to is get the junior out of your title
and three is improve your coding chops
so there's this idea of t-shaped people
somebody came up with it I don't know
who they are but if you think about the
letter T
it's got like a horizontal long top with
a long vertical stem and essentially
what you're wanting to say is I have
been experienced I have been exposed to
a lot of things in programming but I'm
really good at this one thing and this
is where like t-shaped people I will
hire these people all day every day and
so this is where you want to say like
yeah I've
made a couple api's I have done like
some DevOps see things and I've built
some friends but I really love ember Jas
and that's where I spend most of my time
contributing and so really this is like
being going from a junior to just a
software engineer this is probably the
hardest thing figure out what you're
interested in and then work on
developing the sim of your T so let's
say you're really into X how do you
prove that
some things that I recommend is like
open source you'll probably using tools
that revolve around X so like if you
like d3 go sign up for the deep 3 repo
look at other libraries built on d3
start trying to contribute back to these
things write an article comparing d3 to
three.js I don't think that's actually a
good comparison but anyways complete
like one serious side project that lets
that shine blog about this how do you do
a non-trivial d3 project from scratch
even if you feel like it's repetitive
and people have done it it's still
important for you to do it and just for
example when I was like I'm really into
ember jeaious I was like how do I
actually prove that to people and then I
went looked this is open source I've
done and launch projects on my own
here's projects that I've contributed to
actual full side projects articles talks
it's just like if this is a court case
it would be really easy to prove that I
really like in verge is it's a very
specific thing but when somebody is like
I need somebody to do in purchase and
I'm like here's my resume they're like I
want you to help me so like that's
really what you wear you want to get um
getting junior out of your title what's
the easiest way to get junior out of
your title stop calling yourself a
junior that seems like really dumb
advice but like after you get your first
job drop it you're not a junior anymore
you're always just a software engineer
every organization is going to have
different standards from junior to
senior so don't try to sell yourself to
something just like explain why I'm an
engineer here's what I love some things
you can do to really help you with this
also is have a regular practice of
learning from people and resources that
are better
you and practice the things you learn
and then focus on one thing at a time
I'm just gonna throw a couple things
that I've historically found really
helpful I'll publish the slides and you
can refer to them later if you're new to
computer science and have a
non-traditional background the base CS
podcast is amazing
it breaks down usually like pompe
academic things like data structures and
b-trees and traversal of recursive blah
blah was like breaks it down into ways
it's really easy to understand
you don't know J yes it's like a great
like I do JavaScript every day and I
want to know more about this Eric
Elliott writes on on medium a lot his
stuffs great there's this book called
pooter which is practical object
oriented design in Ruby it's like
there's a lot of great like architecture
books you can start reading and starting
and start like improving like different
domains of your programming skills Ruby
tapas fun fun function is a great
javascript one there's more this guy
super grumpy but as screencast or great
upcase is another one that's like really
good this is where I solve a like get
the junior out of your title it's
literally like you watch really good
programmers pear on hard problems and
you end up learning an amazing amount by
doing this and when you're comfortable
enough which should be now read the
open-source repos you use it's my Sauk
one source reference I promise so open
source projects are literally like play
books about how to make the things you
like so you can just like read how to do
it and it's like oh my gosh I can make
d3 now I don't know why I chose to e3 I
never used to u3 and learn how to use a
debugger I don't know that's a hard one
but it's useful and also learned how to
do TDD same so and another thing is like
when you're ready to actually start
applying for jobs you need to make sure
that you're your coding chops are like
up to snuff which is like more of a
matter of discipline do an hour of
hacker rank every day read the cracking
the code interview book this book is
amazing like nobody remembers all this
stuff but if I had to look for a new job
I would get a six-pack a redbull and
read this over one weekend and like
that's where I would start Impostors
handbook is another great one and then
interview cake again I'll post all these
so like if you're looking for specific
resources reach out to me I will help
you match like what I think would make
the most sense for your ass okay so
preparing to look for a job you can
prove to me you're interested in one or
two very specific technical things this
is a very important thing you have a
consistent practice of learning from
high-quality sources like hour a day two
hours on the weekend whatever it is like
continue to learn things and you can
also easily solve a wide variety of
programming challenges okay now we're on
to the job hunt this is all about
networking positioning negotiation I
really just want to put this in my
slides it's not really relevant to what
we're talking about networking heroic
Eric says go to meet up in conferences
this is where I've gotten most of my
jobs from Alex an engineer I work with
says meet actual engineers for applying
message me and buy me coffee I will tell
you exactly what things are like this is
great advice like I actually knew
somebody who the way that they would
start applying for a job they would find
an open-source repo for a company they
wouldn't apply for start opening issues
and pull requests against it and use
that to like apply like what open-source
have you done well have you seen your
projects you didn't update this and I
did like it's it's an OK way to do that
this is also extremely opinionated but
in my opinion the best jobs come from
direct recommendations then applying for
companies you like and then literally
everything else and I'm not gonna like
poopoo on recruiters or job boards or
anything they're all great but if you
have a friend who will say I like
working at my job that's huge like
that's somebody you want to work with
that is like the easiest way to know
you're getting into a situation that you
like so again make connections
contribute to open source to go to
meetups go to conferences speaking me up
some conferences if you can apply for
contracting positions at companies this
is easy because if you do a bad job they
don't have to pay you after a week like
be like hey I would love to do some
consulting for your contracting for you
and then Twitter like a madman or mad
person the last time I
that I was out of a job I had three job
offers from Twitter just because I'd
read about programming stuff this is
like an amazing thing
so positioning what kind of company do
you want to work for what matters to you
do you want to be remote does salary
matter it's a tech SEC matter this is
your team matter this kind of needs to
inform what type of jobs you start to
look for startups big companies
consultancies going out on your own do
you want to work for like oh you or a
government thing when you kind of have
this like if you want to work at macro
corp like update your LinkedIn don't
have weird stuff on social media buy
some nice business casual clothes do
whatever these people do like be like
them this is this is a job you want this
is a lifestyle you want like figure out
how these people work in just like like
emulate them in a way that's not like
I'm forgetting who I am but like these
are the people you want to fit in with
so like start fitting in with them now
if you want to work at startup Li like
by a MacBook and a hoodie like but you
say like start to taking pictures you
want a and post my Instagram these are
like these will help you fit in and kind
of understand how these people think and
work again know how to fit in know how
to be yourself know how to stand out so
when you're applying when you're like
working on companies you're like I want
to apply it start up lay your Mac micro
Corp macro Corp like you need to kind of
do some research on these companies what
are their core values their mission
statement what is their financial health
key personnel Google the company and
figure out what what they say on their
social media figure out who their
competitors are and when you start
interviewing like I know people know
that they're interviewing with me at
least a week ahead of time it's like
it's really easy to figure out what I'm
into so if you start like if you open up
with like react versus Amber joke I'll
probably be like oh this guy is funny
he's no city's like he's controlling me
I think that's great
then for every company you interview to
you need to add them to like I have this
like spreadsheet there's actually a
better way to explain this it needs to
look like this like when you're
interviewing you just have like you're
connecting all these dots and like
looking
all of your opportunities so in
negotiation it's super hard but your
salary in negotiation which routinely
takes less than five minutes
to conclude has an outsized influence on
what your compensation is the difference
in five thousand or ten thousand dollars
to a company is chump change it's
nothing it's an HR gimmick so like you
need to do a little bit of research
about what companies are offering
because they game they game the system
to give you as little as possible not
everybody but like you just need to you
need to look out for yourself also like
apply for a wide variety of positions
specifically if this is one of your
first jobs the only successful way to
leverage your salary up higher that I've
seen is to use offers from other
companies it is not it is not playing
like you're not playing anybody like the
companies are playing against each other
this this guy right here he was a
professional poker player who turned
into a a like software engineer and he
basically started getting like $80,000
offers and he this whole blog post is
how as eventually he ended up getting a
$250,000 offer from like companies
playing against each other which I'm not
saying like that's a rule I wish I had
that kind of offer I don't but like it's
interesting you should definitely go do
a little bit of research here and again
it should feel like this if it if it
doesn't feel like this you're not you
know hunting for jobs right let's see I
actually don't care about that right now
this is actually a really good story but
Stephanie Hobart kind of talks about her
whole like career trajectory so go read
this later but I'm kind of wanting to
run out of time so again the job hunt
this is all like super basic stuff have
a resume post on social media looking
for a job
portfolio side projects and personal
side are up to date and operational
nothing's weird saan your social media
network constantly and apply everywhere
and so 34 minutes and we're finally to
the fearless interview and it's going to
be a lot like the X in the story
you may be very surprised at how little
is here why because your whole journey
in your software development career is
what allows you to have fearless
interviews it's the side projects it's
the open source it's the networking
that's what prepares you to fight the
boss battle if your level one and you're
trying to go against this like deity
dude there's nothing you can do to
prepare you just have to go kill picks
in the woods until you level up like but
that being said I will talk a little bit
about the logistics of interview because
I think it helps a lot there's usually
three parts intros some type of
challenge and then questions at the end
so this is maybe my favorite piece of
advice in any of my programmer friends
gave me be prepared to answer or
volunteer the what is the one thing you
built that you're most proud of David
said if people can answer this well
that's the leading indicator if you'll
hire them or not and it's never let him
down specifically he looks forward do
you care about what you're building do
you understand what you're building as
it's something that I personally can
connect with also on intros my little
piece of logistical advice if you're
signing up for a car you're something if
you're trying to interview at a company
sign up for their service have a
critical opinion about what they do
understanding a little bit of business
context can really drive the
conversation when you're interviewing so
if it's like an arrow tracking software
sign up for them and then their
competitor like one of the biggest
things I've ever got dinged on with an
interview is I applied it a place I
didn't sign up for it I didn't really
know what they do and like the first
thing was like tell me about why you
wanted to interview with us specifically
what did you think about our product and
it's like you basically can't walk your
way out or around that so like if you do
this it's one of the like most
insightful pieces that you can do to
help prepare the challenge this is like
people's most stressed out like if you
read the title probably what you thought
I was going to talk about it's like 300
tips to defeat the programming challenge
and the thing is like there are some
it's like read this
and do this like but but that's awesome
it is there's no tricks it's like hard
work and then you just have to be ready
I will tell you the challenges typically
come in three flavors there's usually
like the especially if you're doing
front-end stuff like react or ember or
view it's like build a component like an
autocomplete or a star rating UI which
is where things like the JavaScript
already come in handy like as you're
interviewing just build small dumb
things so you're ready to do that
the other one is like building a crud
app so like specifically with full stack
or back in positions I would expect that
you could test drive like basic crud
operations on an API like that's a
pretty common common challenge and so
like this is stuff like to do MVC the
blog and then another one is explain a
solution to hypothetical problem this is
easily the most frustrating one because
it's super objective no subjective it's
like I don't like white we don't do
white boarding in our interview process
other than like like if you want to like
explain a system with like some
flowcharts there's like a white board
available but well I think white board
coding is just dumb but I mean if you
use that it is dumb so don't use that
but but if you're interviewing for a
place like again I think I don't know if
Google still does this but like when I
read through this it's like part of
their coding problem is like pseudo code
on the white board so like if you want
to work for a place in they're a really
good company
like sometimes their interview process
just has this you need to be prepared
for it it's all part it's like part of
the game and again read this book
cover-to-cover
build dumb things and you'll be fine
I've never been in a coding like I've
never been an interview so first of all
for your first couple of interviews
you're gonna do a bad job probably I did
like a lot of people do this is just
like you don't go from like I learned to
play guitar on YouTube to I'm playing
with Celine Dion in one set like you
just have to play like you have to kind
of hat you're gonna have some interviews
you're gonna have to kind of figure out
how to do things
but as long as you're preparing you'll
get there you get better every time
Union one of my favorite interviewers
says practice going through the problem
and thinking out loud practices
explaining what you're trying to do when
you're coding or explaining then coding
which is actually a good skill Esteban
who is another amazing interviewer says
practice on things like a crank be ready
to solve an algorithm probably know the
difference know how to explain the
efficiency of what you're doing what if
you want to know how to do that read the
green book for me have your IDE and
programming environment ready if you say
you do ember you better have in Brazil I
installed and be ready to go if you say
you do react have create react app
installed and ready to go we usually try
to have like bootstrapped environments
ready but there was a time when we
didn't and there's plenty of people who
don't so like if it's like hey I want to
see you because something in react and
you're not set up you're burning like 20
minutes of your interview trying to
figure out how to get something seven
eight just like it looks bad even though
it shouldn't be bad on you it does look
bad and then questions always have a
physical list of questions you're
wanting to ask the employer make a
couple of them personal based on things
you've read and make a couple of them
very general there's usually some time
when the interviewer goes do you have
any questions for me on most of our like
more senior people this is one of the
biggest things that they look at when
they interview people is what questions
they ask back
questions I usually ask which I think
you're like pretty good to write on your
everytime list that you can just like
have ready it's like how do your
engineer sell disagreements what is your
biggest concern going into the next
quarter how what this is this one's
actually amazing how likely are you to
recommend that one of your friends works
here because like if they're like like
if you go back to like where I talked
about where can you get the best job is
from your friend that that you know
likes their job so that kind of helps
you understand the culture how does
communication work here describe the
company culture this is pretty vague but
like if people have like dirty laundry
to air they're going to
you it here and you're gonna know you
want to know this ahead of time what's
your favorite and least favorite thing
about working here how do you know
you're doing a good job at work again
and then like have some other ones like
if you read that they just closed the
big funding round I'd be like how's the
house closing the funding round changed
your hiring process like what is the
morale like after you just closed this
massive series B or something I just be
ready to talk about things that these
people know about you'll make a personal
connection with them and you'll seem
like you're already on the team and
finally if you use sublime text buy a
license before you interview with me if
you click Save in the police by sublime
cop pops up it's just like losing points
for no reason that's kind of personal
preference but so again the fearless
interview review your dossier before
every interview that Evernote filed that
you have on this company that's like
you've done your research your local
coding environment should be set up
you've solved hundreds of algorithm
problems and done dozens of dummy
components and apps which just happens
over time your networking constantly at
meetups and conferences you're regularly
applying on job boards listing sites and
through recruiters and everything else
you can think of if you do these things
you can get a job at whatever company
you want so your thanks if you're
somebody who has this fantasy job I love
my job and I think that I'm there like
I'm sure like I'll think that about
every job from here but like like I just
love what I do now I work remotely I've
got two kids my water cooler is having
goldfish with my three-year-old
I love ember that's like I get to work
with my favorite technology I love my
team help other people get there there's
a lot of people that are making less
than they're capable of right now
getting into a program the the
technology industry can amplify their
quality of life
it can help it can be the difference
between my family has enough to make it
and not so like have us having
programming jobs if you have them help
bootstrap people to get into these jobs
like I think that's part of our
responsibility being in a good job is
helping other people get there so share
your journey there are people looking
like this at you no matter what stage of
the journey you're on encourage the
future heroes and that's where I will
end also if you have finished free code
camp I will happily interview you and
tell you what I think like just to help
get the jitters out so message me on
social media if there's a flood of
people I will find other people to
interview you don't worry about it like
if this is this is your big stumbling
block we can fix that together